Miss Universe crowns a new winner but  noon Miss Universe is as Fergie sizzles  during a powerful performance it was a  big night in Las Vegas as 92 women  competed for the title of Miss Universe  2017 the final two Miss South Africa  Demi Linnell Peters and Miss Colombia  Laura Gonzales but only one can take the  crown the new Miss Universe is  so Africa the 22 year old who recently  earned her degree in business management  with clearly overwhelmed with joy and  emotion but it wasn't the only highlight  of the evening  [Music]  fergie electrified the stage as she  performed her new single a little work  the 42 year old singer dazzled in a  silver and black sparkly striped mini  dress which was right on point with the  contestants during the evening gown  portion of the night  [Music]